哈囉大家好,我是熊熊
歡迎來到這個讓你越來越有錢的頻道
說到技術指標,可能會讓大家聯想到
它普遍存在延遲性的問題
也就是容易錯過一大段行情
指標才產生出訊息
而竟然有個指標
不僅能降低延遲性帶來的影響
連大戶的一舉一動都逃不出它的手掌心
也就是OBV能量潮指標
而這指標會如此強大的原因
都要歸咎於市場一個慣性
也就是價格漲跌,是由成交價所推動
而大家最常听到的技术指标
像是MACD、RSI、KD等
都是由价格作为基础所计算出来的
而OBB能量潮指标
是以推动价格之前的成交量
作为指标形成的判断根据
因此就可以在指标延迟之前
事先知道市场的脉络
造就市场里有一句经典名言
新手看价、老手看量
因此成交量是在我们进场之前
必须要研究的重要指标
如果你想避免被割韭菜
并且跟随大户的脚步轻松赚钱
那你一定要学会
这个强大的指标
而这期影片为你统整了
OBB指标里
两个交易的核心重点
第一点
OBB指标的特性与目的
要做任何判断之前
一定要清楚它能帮助我们
解决交易上什么样的问题
否则你懂在座的判断方式
最终还是会失败收场
因此我们必须先清楚
OBB指标的特性与目的
才能真正领悟到
第二点里所说的
OBB指标在实战中
三种最有价值的运用方式
我们要知道
任何的判断方式
最重要的并不是追求准确性
而是使用在对的时机
才能发挥出它的最大成效
因此就让我们透过这集影片
让OBB指标帮助我们
拥有稳固且强大的赚钱能力
因为我这频道就是为了帮助你
透过投资理财以及财产思维
来让你越来越有钱的频道
所以只要按下订阅
并开启小铃铛
就不会错过每周更新的影片
确保你也走在致富的道路上
在影片最后也会教你
如何辨识大户进入市场的时机
就能及时搭上顺风车
掌握到那最关键的暴涨行情
那首先说到第一点
OBB指标的特点与目的
要说到OBB指标的特点
只要从它的计算公式里
就可以一目了然
也就是它与成交量之间密布可分的关系
在指标中显示的OBB指
是以累积成交量的形式做计算
意思是如果今日收盘价
高于前一日收盘价
OBB就会是正值
則今日收盤價低於前一日的收盤價OBV就呈現負值而如果今日與前一日的收盤價持平就不會做計算因此就會以正負值的增減做累積表現出OBV形成的曲線
舉例以日線作為計算週期
則計算公式就是
當日OBV值等於本日OBV值
加上前一日的OBV值
可以看到它都是以成交量做計算
既然成交量是在價格之前
那OBV被稱作是個領先於價格的指標
也就無庸置疑了
而為什麼學會OBV指標
可以讓你提前發現大戶的脈絡
因為大戶進場必定有成交量
這個是大戶無法隱藏的
所以只要我們找到量
就能夠找到大戶的蹤跡
而OBV指標在整齒盤面裡
我們先打開看盤的介面
然後搜尋OBV指標
它和以往的指標很不同
就是它不用設置參數
這有個很大的優勢
就是不會對於參數者的高低
有效果的差異性
而上面所看到的MA設置
是在指標之間要搭配運用時才需要做顯示
而我們這次是針對OBB的運用進行解析
所以MA設置不影響使用
因此不需要理會它
如果大家對於MA與OBB相互運用
想要了解的朋友也歡迎下方留言
而打開OBB可以很直觀地看到
它就是一條單一的曲線
且走勢和圖表上的K棒其實有點相似
像是在OBB上有個高峰
圖表裡也就出現個高峰
如果指標出現低谷
圖表也會很明顯的看到低谷
因此成交量與價格兩者之間的關係
在實戰的運用中
將會是關鍵的訊息所在
那再來我們就來一探究竟
第二點
OBV指標在實戰中
最有價值的運用方式
任何技術指標的判斷
會因為運用的時機點不同
產生判斷的目的
也就有所不同
於是我統整三種
OBV的運用方式
能針對我們的交易策略
所缺乏的進行補足
進而優化我們的交易系統
而這裡要注意的是
OBB是以成交量的變化所形成
所以我們會以交易系統裡
參考值高的大週期做運用
對於使用週期不清楚的朋友
也能參考之前的影片
交易週期使用錯誤將注定賠錢
來了解詳細內容
先說到第一種運用方式
利用OBB確認趨勢
來提高獲利空間的用法
我們將徐序漸進的
先了解它的判斷方式
在單鍵盤面來進行運用
就能更明確它的使用流程
来达成良好的应用成果
可以发现当OBB曲线
与价格同涨或同跌时
也就表示趋势得到确认如果OBB创新高而价格也跟创新高表示上升趨勢將持續上行則如果OBB創新低價格也創新低則下跌趨勢就會持續下行
因此這時我們就沿著
OBB指標的方向進行操作
不僅更加安全
也能提高行情的增長空間
在圖表裡我們可以看到
游標指的位置
形成當時OBB的高點
而我們對照上方的K棒
被OBB的成交量推動著
因此讓K棒價格也形成高點
这时我们就会确认趋势将会持续向上运行
因此我们就会以多方的策略来进行交易
反之我们看到游标的位置形成当时OBV的低点
而对照上方的K棒也形成低点
这时我们就会确认趋势还会持续向下跌
因此我们就会以空方的策略来进行交易
所以如果你不知道该如何判断趋势方向
就能利用OBV这个判断方式
简单直观的做辨识
第二种运用方式
便是趋势转变的关键时机
当OBB指标创新低
但价格却没有创下新低
代表当时价格与指标
产生了背离的状况
这时也就出现了强烈的多头讯号
行情将会从向下趋势
转变成上升趋势
则如果OBB指标创新高
但价格却没有创下新高
这时产生的背离
则表示空头讯号
这也就是趋势方向转变的关键所在
我们在图表里可以看到
在下方OBB指標裡
第一個圈起來的低點
與下一個創新低
圈起來的位置
對照上方K棒
第一個圈起來的低點
與下一個圈起來的低點
並沒有創新低
反而低點位是變高的
而這就產生了背離的現象
行情也從下降趨勢
轉變成為上升趨勢
因此如果這次場上
持有空單的交易
就會選擇出場
轉變成以多頭策略為主
相反的OBB指標裡
我們第一個圈起來的高點
與下一個圈起來的高點
有创新高
然后对照上方K棒
第一个圈起来的高点
与下一个圈起来的高点
并没有创新高
也就产生了背离的现象
因此这时如果场上
持有多单的交易
就会选择出场
转变成以空单策略为主
可以看到往后行情
也就呈现下降趋势的运行
因此对于交易时
当不清楚趋势是否转变方向
上升与下降趋势之间
相互转换的讯号
就可以利用这方法来做辨识
再来就要说到
如何辨識大戶進入市場
來掌握關鍵的暴漲時機
也就是第三點
如何在震盪後的第一時間找到奪空強勢的動能所在這時我們就能利用OBV以量能帶動價格的特性讓行情處於震盪時對於趨勢發出動能的時機提供了很關鍵的訊號
也就是當價格出現震盪
而OBV指標在往後的曲線
向上突破區間震盪時
也就表示多方動能湧入
這時也就能作為買掌做多的訊號
而當價格處於震盪
OBV指標在這期間
向下跌破震盪區間時
則表示進場做空的訊號
而我们在图表里可以看到
左边的直线到右边的直线之间
价格处于震荡走势
而对照到下方的OVV
我们用水平线
拉出震荡期间的高低位
然后往后的OVV
向下穿过下方水平线时
这时我们就可以作为空方动能涌入
也就是进场做空的讯号
而往后行情也看到
持续的向空头走势运行
相反的当价格处于震荡
高点与低点的水平线
往后穿过上方的水平线时
這時我們就可以作為多方動能湧入
買掌做多的訊號
但這裡要注意的是
任何指標的運用都要有個觀念
就是不能單獨做使用
而是要滿足其他條件
才能作為進場的時機
因此這時我們要留意
K方這時是否符合空轉多的反轉訊號
表示指標多方動能湧入
與K方訊息是一致的
因此我們看群奇來的地方
先是看到空方後
形成盤整
然後產生多方訊號
這也就是標準的反轉訊號
表示当时指标多方动能
将会持续带动价格上涨
往后行情也如期快速上涨
否则如果忽略到K棒价格的运用
指标产生进场讯号
就贸然的进场
往后行情将容易产生
向下回调的情况
造成买在近期高点位的结果
因此这集影片我们可以看到
OBB针对不同的目的
所运用的时机点不同
因此我们可以
遵照我们策略中
如果要确认趋势
往后是否还有动能
就可以使用第一种运用方式
来确认趋势是否会持续运行
如果是想辨识
趋势方向是否改变
则可以使用第二种
来辨识趋势转变的关键时机
而第三种将可以让你
在大户涌入交易量时
跟随着大户的脚步
轻松地掌握市场的红利
希望这集影片
能透过OBB指标
帮助你更直观地
辨识市场的变化
如果影片中
有任何对你有所帮助的地方
也请为这部影片点个赞
并且分享出去
最后如果有
还没订阅熊狼的朋友
現在還來得及
請務必按下訂閱並開啟小鈴鐺
感謝大家收看
我們下期影片不見不散
拜拜囉